face carving killers
whale carcasses pod people from beyond
the stars keep watching for more
near-perfect horror movies if you dare
based on jean reddon's novel of the same
name eyes without a face follows dr
genassiere a plastic surgeon who feels
responsible for the role he played in
the accident that disfigured his
daughter christine with the help of his
laboratory assistant louise dr
jeanacier's desperation drives him to
abduct and peel the faces off young
women so he can relieve his infantilized
daughter and her creepy featureless
plastic mask according to criterion when
the film premiered in france the
audience dropped like flies especially
during the infamously graphic surgical
scene but the film enjoyed an
enthusiastic critical re-evaluation
during its 1986 theatrical re-release
and has since claimed a spot in cinema
history as a masterful and even poetic
piece of body horror cinema slate's
david edelstein writes eyes without a
face is among the most disturbing horror
films ever made eyes without a face
enjoys an average 98 fresh rating on
rotten tomatoes and came in at number 38
in timeout's list of the 100 best horror
films it holds a meta score of 90.
co-directed by marion c cooper and
ernest b shoudsak king kong follows an
adventurous film crew that discovers the
eighth wonder of the world a giant
prehistoric ape who falls head over
heels for the beautiful and darrow
kong's romantic aspirations are foiled
however when the crew abduct him to new
york city where the monstrous monkey
promptly wreaks havoc sporting a
weighted average meta score of 90 and a
99 approval rating on rotten tomatoes
kong was a technical marvel for its time
boasting groundbreaking technology such
as stop-motion animation and matte
paintings as roger ebert puts it in his
great movies write-up in the very
artificiality of some of the special
effects there is a creepiness that isn't
there in today's slick flawless
computer-aided images indeed there's
something unnervingly tactile about
kong's stuttering movements something
primeval and ancient that rhymes nicely
with the film's mystique as one of the
true milestones of hollywood movie
making it wasn't the airplanes
it was beauty kill the beast
sitting pretty with a 90 metacritic
score alfred hitchcock's the birds did
for birds what jaws would do for sharks
a decade later a sub-genre defining
creature feature the film's swarms of
avian adversaries aren't so much
individual animals as they are a force
of nature a furious storm of beating
wings and pecking beaks with unknown
motivations but a clear murderous
objective when the film first premiered
in 1963 it was met with mixed reviews
rejected in part for its overt
allegiance to the lowly trappings of
exploitation cinema and yet the passage
of time won out and the critical tide
turned in hitch's favor the birds now
holds the number 7 spot on the american
film institute's list of the greatest
american thrillers all told hitchcock's
movie remains a creepy high-flying
benchmark when it comes to killer animal
flicks here's to never going outside
ever again
a controversial gothic tale of tragedy
and psychosis disgrace director roman
polanski's first english language film
is widely praised as one of cinema's
most unsettling portraits of mental and
emotional disintegration a fragile young
belgian manicurist named carol suffers
from a debilitating fear of men when her
sister and roommate helen leaves their
shabby apartment for an italian getaway
with a married man carol retreats deeper
into her own fractured mind where
visitations have feverish and ultimately
violent consequences following its
premiere at the 1965 cannes film
festival repulsion was met with sizable
critical acclaim as a small but piercing
human tragedy for a 1965 review in the
new york times the film enjoys a
near-perfect 95 approval rating on
rotten tomatoes and clocks in at number
54 on timeout's list of the 100 best
horror movies an impressive sophomore
effort that will surely intrigue fans of
claustrophobic terror trips repulsion is
a classic chiller well deserving of its
91 metacritic score
don't let frankenstein's age fool you
james whale's 1931 adaptation of mary
shelley's novel packs an enormous
harrowing punch boasting a legendary and
alarmingly sympathetic performance by
boris karloff as the monster
frankenstein tells of an obsessive
doctor driven to restore life to a
creature assembled out of scraps of
rotting flesh while dr frankenstein's
experiment proved successful the
piecemeal creature is confused
traumatized and unable to move
peacefully through the world of the
living ingrained in the pop culture
consciousness and saddled with the
burden of historical relevance it's
tempting to hold frankenstein at arm's
length but its reputation as a
masterpiece is fully deserved
frankenstein holds a 100 fresh rating on
rotten tomatoes and frequently places on
both genre-specific lists such as
bravo's 100 scariest movie moments
and broader gauntlets like the new york
times best 1000 movies ever the american
film institute ranked this line as the
49th greatest movie quote in american
cinema
the film claims an outstanding meta
score of 91
son of saul takes place almost entirely
in auschwitz birkenau a complex of
concentration and extermination camps
operated by nazi germany during world
war ii there a jewish hungarian prisoner
named saul serves as a member of a unit
of jewish inmates forced to assist in
the disposal of gas chamber victims the
plot follows saul's dangerous and
desperate attempt to provide a proper
jewish burial for a young boy he adopts
posthumously as his son as christy
lemire astutely notes in her review for
rogerebert.com son of saul tackles the
ungraspable horrors of the holocaust by
placing its horrific elements in the
periphery to the end that the suggestion
of suffering is more unsettling than
wallowing in it likewise the film stages
giovanni marchini kamiya lauds the film
as a towering landmark for filmic
fictionalizations of the holocaust when
it debuted it can in 2015 the film was
awarded the grand prix and the
prestigious fapresky prize
later at the 88th academy awards the
film won the oscar for best foreign
language film on metacritic son of saul
holds an impressive score of 91
even without directly invoking the
obvious trappings of the genre hungarian
directors belatar and agnes ranitsky
expertly craft an atmosphere that is
unmistakably and oppressively horrific
vercmeister harmonies takes place in an
anonymous provincial town in the dead of
winter despite the biting cold
townspeople gather to gape at the main
attraction of the traveling circus that
now occupies the town square the massive
stuffed carcass of a whale people come
from far and wide to gape at the bloated
monster but over time the tension
between the townsfolk and the gawking
visitors becomes unbearable and erupts
into violence like much of tar's work
vercmeister harmonies is the dictionary
definition of slow cinema composed of 39
long dreamlike single camera shots that
play out languidly over the course of
the film's 145 minute run time when the
film was released in 2000 it was met
with critical acclaim and prays for as
the guardians richard williams puts it a
bleak vision of chaos and capitalism
according to a statistical breakdown
from they shoot pictures don't they the
film is presently the 34th most
critically acclaimed film of the 21st
century unsurprisingly it boasts a 92
score on metacritic
in a chilling blend of science fiction
and horror don siegel's 1956 film
invasion of the body snatchers is one of
the most astute political allegories of
1950s america released at the height of
the cold war the film's acute vision of
insidious conformity struck an
anti-communist nerve while flirting with
a more seditious critique of the tyranny
of the mccarthy era
[Music]
based on jack finney's serialized 1954
sci-fi novel the body snatchers the film
follows a small town doctor as he slowly
uncovers the truth about the recent
unsettling changes in his sleepy
community namely the town is quietly
being invaded by an alien presence who
gestate in massive seeds and take over
people's bodies as they sleep producing
emotionless indistinguishable carbon
copies of the original person
boasting a 92 metascore and an
impressive 98 approval rating on rotten
tomatoes in 2008 the american film
institute recognized the film as the
ninth best entry in the science fiction
genre steeped in unchecked paranoia and
alienation invasion of the body
snatchers is a taut and atmospherically
tense horror film with very little
horror on screen all the better to wreak
horrific havoc on your imagination
adapted from daphne du maurier's short
story of the same name
1973's don't look now is a trauma-laced
slow dive that feels unavoidably like
the logical extension of family grief
it's a protracted nightmare that muddles
the line between a psychological break
and the genuinely supernatural the movie
follows a married couple who moved to
venice after the death of their young
daughter christine confined in the
city's elegant decay they both begin to
experience a series of terrifying and
increasingly dangerous occurrences that
defy explanation tempted by the
irrational notion that their daughter
might still be alive the couple form a
disturbing friendship with two sisters
one of whom claims to be clairvoyant
directed by nicholas rogue a former
cinematographer with an undeniable eye
for color and composition
don't look now is a breathtaking
marriage of jalo tropes and pulpy
intrigue the film also features one of
the most memorable final scenes in genre
film a remarkable climax that cements
the film's reputation as an all-time
great with a meta score of 95 rogue's
stylish examination of the maddening
power of loss is essential viewing for
genre fans we belong dead
those three immortal words encapsulate
the macabre heartache of bride of
frankenstein james whale's crushing
follow-up to his iconic gothic monster
flick
amazingly bride is one of those rarities
in cinema a sequel that is better than
the original picking up right where the
first film left off bride of
frankenstein reconnects with a deranged
doctor who has fallen back under the
spell of his former mentor dr pretorius
when pretorius encourages his pupil to
resume his experiments and create a mate
for the monster the shattered
frankenstein finds that he cannot refuse
frequently identified as the crown jewel
of universal monster movies pride of
frankenstein's overarching theme about a
relationship society doesn't deem
natural retains its relevance to this
day
and it's all the more heartbreaking
considering whale himself was openly gay
with a fantastic 95 on metacritic bride
of frankenstein is a must-watch for
anyone looking to see what all the fuss
is about when it comes to classic era
horror films
in 1967 a horror novel graced the annual
bestsellers list of publishers weekly
for the first time in 30 years
rosemary's baby by ira levin a precision
thriller about the devil impregnating a
woman on the upper west side levin's
novel was swiftly adapted into a film
just one year after its publication
starring mia farrow as the titular
rosemary and john cassavetes as her
husband guy roman polanski's satanic
slowburn frequently tops best of lists
for good reason in 2014 rosemary's baby
was selected by the library of congress
for preservation in the national film
registry and in 2010 the guardian ranked
it as the second greatest horror film of
all time ruth gordon's performance as
mini cast vet the nosy neighbor quite
literally from hell earned her an
academy award for best supporting
actress
it would be the last oscar awarded to a
horror movie until 1991's the silence of
the lambs
every film ambling under the umbrella of
elevated horror owes an immense demonic
debt to rosemary's baby and its
revolutionary vision of satanists as
ordinary folks who might pass you in the
street with uncomfortably long takes
claustrophobic set design and immersive
trance-like pacing this is a film that
wheels and deals in pure psychological
horror it's more than worthy of its 96
meta score
psycho begins with a deceptively
conventional setup marian crane a real
estate clerk embezzles a sizeable chunk
of change from her employer in the hope
of starting a new life when she's caught
in a torrential downpour she takes
refuge at the bates motel an isolated
establishment run by norman bates a
quirky mama's boy who probably wouldn't
even hurt a fly probably we all go a
little mad sometimes
transitioning from a straightforward
noir to something far nastier psycho's
unsettling portrait of a predatory
peeping tom remains as forceful today as
it was in 1960 while the film's devious
rug pulls are now widely known psycho
continues to function as one of the most
gripping and suggestive entries in the
horror thriller sub-genre with a leering
camera that often mirrors its predatory
subject the movie actively revels in the
sinful voyeuristic allure of cinema
itself twisting the act of watching into
something deviant and transgressive
it makes perfect sense then that alfred
hitchcock's enduring masterwork boasts a
near flawless 97 on metacritic
[Music]